[Music]
well the full story is now out from mike
silver of nfl media we had a snippet to
discuss yesterday and it came from aaron
rodgers questioning the wisdom of
restricting his ability to change plays
the line of scrimmage in the new matlab
floor offense the full story makes it
clear that there is a pressure point as
it relates to what leflore called the
audible thing because the way they do
the offense chris yep they've got two
plays that they come out of the huddle
with and the quarterback is taught
how to
determine based upon specific criteria
which of the two plays will work given
the defense that he sees and that's it
that's your freedom you've got two
choices and you're told how to make that
decision by the coaching staff
aaron rodgers wants more freedom than
that and both guys are talking freely
about it that's the thing that astounds
me more than anything else that they are
openly talking about this thing that is
unresolved and may be resolved in
lafleur's favor and may be resolved in
rogers well i think one it's a positive
thing that they are speaking out about
it like that publicly how how is that
positive because how can you twist that
into a positive because it just shows
that it's not tension that they're
willing to go like hey yeah this is my
offense and matt lafleur i learned this
from kyle shanahan and yes this is the
way it's implemented
but he's realizing damn i got one of the
greatest of all time and he's done a few
things here and he might be able to
teach me a few things at the line of
scrimmage too so i do i think they're
hashing it out i'd rather hear it you
know this way than you know a little
bickering here and there and it's not
getting hashed out you know first off
the context of aaron rodgers quote
yesterday and everything certainly looks
a lot different when the article starts
out with matt lafleur addressing the
audible thing right to start it off so i
mean again we all wanted to take shots
at rogers for being passive aggressive
and why he said it but obviously this is
a real conversation that's going up
there in green bay and they're gonna
have to find you know what works for
them you know what i don't know am i
crazy mike as awesome as i think the
kyle shanahan sean mcvay offense is you
know i would think matt lefleur would be
crazy and would want also rogers to make
some of these things that the line of
scrimmage happened that he's done so
well in years before they just got to
figure out what formations what
personnel to do it in but it's only
going to help lefleur's offense and make
rogers more comfortable within his
offense if you give them a little bit of
that flexibility
isn't that something you get resolved
though like on your way through the door
when you hire the guy like shouldn't
mark murphy the ceo of the team
understand that matt laflore comes from
that kyle shanahan kid playing madden
level of control over a quarterback and
i remember during the lockout in 2011. i
mentioned this last hour rex grossman
knew that he was going to be the
starting quarterback in washington
because he was going to do everything
shanahan wanted the quarterback to do
that's how you impress kyle shanahan you
do exactly what he tells you to do and
if lafleur's bringing that to town it
just seems like they should be on the
same page in that regard the moment he's
hired not as we're going into this four
to six week low before the start of
training camp where they have to figure
out exactly what they're going to do
because now they're back into
no contact mode yeah you can't work it
out now you're gonna have to work it out
when you convene training camp in late
july and into early august yeah well i
think the thing you know these are
conversations that go on organically you
know as you install the offense and do
those things first off you know matt
lafleur has not proven that he's kyle
shanahan or sean mcvay yet right we all
want to see it to believe it we know
that there's a lot of positives there i
never doubted that he might be a head
coach one day do i think it's a little
early yes but his offense didn't
necessarily just blow me away last year
with the tennessee titans it did not so
i would think he'd want rogers to have
you know some of that line of scrimmage
freedom there but what really happens
mike at least realistically in my mind
with these type of conversations you
know new formation new play rogers asks
a question oh what if they bring this
blitz he goes well hey the offense takes
care of this blitz with this play and
you know rogers goes well you know in
the past when we got this i used to
audible of this and man we would get you
know 10 15 yards off it every time and
now lefleur might go back and look at
the tape and go damn he's right that's
kind of a smart play okay aaron there's
the green light on that formation you
can audible on that one and i just think
it's an ongoing conversation but they
just got to figure out where the line is
to where it goes okay that's too much
for aaron rodgers in the line of
scrimmage and now you're you're ruining
the flow within the offense uh and just
you know having that balance to go no
let the let the offense work and rogers
when things are really bad or in really
trouble this is when you can get us out
of jail here
i went back and looked at the tyler dunn
story from bleacher report from early
april for some clues about this tension
as it relates to aaron rodgers doing too
much and the comparison made by former
packers running back ryan grant was
artificial intelligence that at some
point the ai takes over if you let
rogers do too much he will do too much
and he will freelance and he will tell
the receivers i know you're supposed to
run a flag route run a post route do it
my way right so that that there's
there's i think a range of healthy
freedom that you want to give aaron
rodgers but you don't want to give them
a blank check yeah so at some point
there's going to be a barrier the
question is chris will he accept any
barrier or does he want to have
essentially peyton manning freedom to do
whatever he wants at the line of
scrimmage that's really the issue but i
think you're right that is the issue
yeah where is that barrier and you know
is he comfortable with it when it does
get set down and that'll be on lafleur
and the offense to prove it to rogers to
go hey you don't need to audible all the
time the offense is damn good
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports